by living a longer life is nice in
theory but a longer lifespan can be
accompanied by an array of chronic
health issues there are some ways to
mitigate such conditions joining us with
some advice is Dr Mark verdossian from
Sunset Clinic which has contracted by
Optum Care Network Nevada the sponsors
of this segment Dr fredosi and thanks
for being here thank you you see a lot
of patients 65 and older and you can
there's a difference between those who
are thriving and feeling better and
those who do not and what is one of the
biggest common denominators
I appreciate you having me on Kendall uh
out of the hundreds of patients we see a
week the healthiest patients that we see
are those that are physically active and
those patients seem to come in with no
medications they Thrive and the
longevity of those patients is what
brought me in here today to talk to you
so what constitutes being active
so uh any physical activity is helpful
but there are
moderate and also vigorous activities
before you start any exercise activity
you'd want to talk to your physician to
make sure that you are healthy to start
but moderate activity would be walking
even gardening would give some health
benefits and 150 minutes of that a week
would be all you need to be to remain
healthy now when you get into the more
vigorous activities like swimming and
biking all you need is 75 minutes a week
10 minutes a day and that's very very
beneficial to your health so finding the
time is possible
and consistency I imagine is a big part
of it absolutely yes any physical
activity is beneficial for us especially
as we age but what really helps is
aerobic activity where your heart rate's
slightly elevated and you're
consistently doing the exercise and
consistently staying with it day after
day and that's where we find our
healthiest patients land and finding an
activity that you like I imagine is a
big part of that because if you dread
working out on a daily basis or however
often you're working out you're far less
likely to do it absolutely and then
nutrition is just another big factor
those that remain healthy are the
patients that have a good nutritional
balance as well they keep their weight
down so they can keep active and that
combination seems to keep them the
healthiest yeah and being being socially
active I imagine plays a role 100
percent one of the biggest
benefits of being active is your mental
health and our patients that are healthy
and active are some of the most mentally
health healthy patients that we see
great advice Dr fredosi and really good
to have you here thank you for coming
today appreciate it thanks Optum Care
Network again for sponsoring this
segment they have locations across
Southern Nevada and if you want more
information call that number on the
screen
855-780-5954 or visit optumcare.com
Nevada